[Music]
I'm
man
[Music]
that's a huge
good
morning
[Music]
hat ju hat
shoes
[Music]
dudes
eia Doubtfire dear I specialize in the
education and entertainment of
entertainment of entertainment of
entertainment of entertainment
of's
a
could you make me a Woman Showtime I'm
not a boob guy I know you're used to
Lucy but I run daggers for you daggers
for you I know you're used to Lucy but I
run
go I know you're used to
[Music]
Lucy I know you're used to Lucy but I
run Sur
hip hop hop we're sorry dance till you
drop hip hop hop doesn't mean that they
don't love hip hop hop dance till you
drop hip hop hop me so sorry just a
little bit of
nicotine the sun just a little bit of
nicotine cream in your sugar little bit
of
nicotine doesn't mean that they don't
love you
[Music]
never I know you're us to Lucy but iers
for I'm in charge for I know you're used
to Lucy but I
[Music]
run I know you're used to Lucy but I run
such a sh such a
sh used to but
IUN hip
hop dance till Dr hip hop doesn't mean
they don't love hip
hop dance till you drop hip
[Music]
hop just a little bit of
nicotine the just a little bit of
nicotine cream your
sugar does mean they don't love
[Music]
you I'm in
charge with
[Music]
me
never law enforcement began a quadruple
homicide investigation they don't
they're not going to take your
[Music]
PE still got an overabundance of
freaking Chinese Nationals running
illegal grows I think
everywhere drugs human trafficking
murder
Espionage often times it's someone
that's out of state or a foreign
National that's running these type of
organizations as one ye ya Fu am
I is this essentially a human
trafficking operation we have
identified people who are considered
National Security risks
[Music]
[Applause]
that's what I
know I
know I know
[Music]
Str glad to be with you and I know what
you're thinking hey today's a slow news
day so this will get
inappropriate half of that is right yep
half of that is correct uh it's not a
slow news day it's not but this will be
wildly in appropriate so like we always
say a strong PG-13 and I will sound like
a fat guy out of breath because I can't
breathe through my nose very well with
have the bubonic plag going through this
whole office ripping through this place
it's just tearing through this place I
blame you why I don't know I mean I was
patient zero probably so you sound like
an AI generated voice of Gerald
Morgan I I promise it is me
so um let me let me really quickly hit
the uh The Rundown for you uh Nancy
Pelosi this clip is going viral where
people you know upset that she said go
back to China here's the crazy thing
she's partially right as it relates to
communist Chinese nationalists uh of
course msnbc's been having a really bad
day and then this Trump verdict look
this is something that obviously
happened um a few days ago but there are
some updates here hold on a second I
have a every oh it's just like not
finished anyway what when you don't
sneeze it's awful I had no idea what you
me I have blue
septum
it's the worst comment below don't you
hate when you feel a sne this is going
to bother me for the rest of the
show like I'm one of the seven little
people I guarantee you half the audience
just didn't say a word during that
moment I don't want to distract him
someone's someone need to it scare me no
that's hiccups okay I need to go back to
this though uh bring up that top sheet
again here's the thing with the Trump
verdict um You probably don't know what
it is that you think know or at least
the people you do if you tune into the
show because you checked the references
but the way it's being portrayed in the
media is how they hope history writes
this and it's incorrect and so we wanted
to go through a few key examples of some
things that you may believe and disabuse
you of those Notions for example how
much do you really know about Watergate
what do you know about hands up don't
shoot what do you think happened with
The Alex Jones trial uh we got Peter
Navaro was another one so we have a few
of these cases going you know what this
is one of those things where people
accept oh Donald Trump sexually
assaulted this woman no no no no no
that's not what this verdict is and
there's a huge conflict of interest and
that is the through line this has
happened throughout history this is not
a conspiracy by the way we're not even
getting into it
MLK who who do you guys think took out
MLK honestly you can comment below uh
you know that the FBI was writing him
letters right telling him to kill
himself and he got a gun
permit
approved AA a and if at any point during
today's show of course we will in
trouble you see
this that means head on over to rumble
because uh you know 5,000 of you on
Rumble is more valuable than 500,000 on
YouTube because it's filled with pinko
commies all right Gerald how are you I
am I'm I'm about the same yeah you're
about the same you're still SI I feel a
little bit brighter but that's not going
to help us out all right well then once
you warm up you'll have more to say and
in third chair when you hear this you
know him you love him we thank him for
his service he is going to be in osagi O
I don't know the casino in Panka Pon
City O Sage Casino in city in Ponka City
Saturday Saturday February 17th yeah Mr
firin thank you for being thank you for
your service thank you yeah you're
welcome folks you're welome appreciate
it I uh I'm huh no nothing go no you oh
my gosh I say you're at your hair is at
the length it's the same length as your
beard and you look like Curious George
yeah it's not the it's not my best op I
well I got a haircut this weekend and
then the guy when he he cut he cut this
part too short and then this too and I
have an egg-shaped head and I'm fat at
the bottom so it's a whole thing and
then I only get my haircut by black guys
it's like a policy I have yeah I know
yeah and so I go into this Barber and
they make the haircut and I go dude I
can't I look like an undercover cop the
whole shop loses it laughing and the
guy's like he told you to leave CU
you I was like see dude everyone agrees
get your ass out Ethan hwk you a't go
smoke PCP yeah no no it's a compliment
because your hair is thick and so is
your beard and so you look like a
chimpanzee but the most beloved
chimpanzee you know what else is thick
come on now stop it my legs well that's
it's a children's show uhuh
so here's the video that's been going
viral uh Nancy Pelosi I wanted to say
Paul well because you know Paul yeah
it's Paul Paul likes hammers so all the
pman Pelosi Nancy Pelosi uh this video
went viral yesterday it's not a new
video to be clear but um she was being
confronted by these Pro Palestinian you
know Pro terrorist protesters yeah who
were confronting her on her driveway and
a lot of people are using this as
political football saying oh I can't
believe she would say this it's racist
here's the thing and I hate to ever say
this she may not have been right because
she had done her research but she
happens to be right uh in in a lot of
ways here's the
clip most of your
constituents stop stop the genocide stop
the H the Democrats want the ceasefire
the Democrats want the
ceasefire the Democrats want and by the
way before we continue that's Paul
Pelosi's Porsche in the background did
you guys it is did you see that yeah
yeah yeah zoom
in that's his Porsche right back there
is her husband paos cop okay oh that's
not PP come on bro fool me once I
thought they locked him up I he's back
for seconds he's back out no bail I
think they I think he got out with a
safe
word pel's like go back to China and
take this silicone with you yes
exactly her black assistant like that's
sine she's like I don't the
principal is the same so she's from San
Francisco it's not the first time she
said go back to China no it's not it's
absolutely not here's here's the truth
though the truth is that Nancy Pelosi is
actually right uh the CCP communist
chines part actually financing like
these Pro Palestinian protests in
America really just yep it's a group
called The People's form it's founded by
this Chinese uh National sympathizer Roy
Singham and uh the founder of of I
believe it's is it don don don Shang
news yeah right he's a CCP propaganda uh
Pusher and that's what the paper is it's
propaganda so just to be clear like this
is something she just said it probably
because yes that's got to be it right
she said just go back to China because
she what she really wanted to say was
like the n-word and she
but she can't and so she she probably
just said it because she's old and
slightly like racist I guess but she's
not wrong and you can do some re the
research is available to you all
references are publicly available this
is true we have a piece coming out on
Thursday by the way of uh regarding
illegal grow operations weed Farms here
in the states being bought huge swads of
land directly connected to the Communist
Chinese government Triads and human
trafficking this is a it's true she's
right even though she's wrong but she
didn't mean to be
[Music]
don't delete it off Twitter then yeah I
guess I'll keep it up on X after my
silly Zambian neck scarf remember that
that was the most embarrassing thing
when she kneeled and couldn't get up
she she had to hit the Life Alert
bracelet
somebody help she called for help on her
giant more
like it's just one
it's Hello
Operator so Nancy Pelosi anyway the
point is she but she's she she's she's
she's um a effectless uh communist
sympathizer word yeah exactly uh she's
about as use as as like our guy here
Chad Xavier our resident X-Man is that
guy still around yeah he is do you want
to you you want to go take a look he's
there we have See's doing I'll see what
he's up to let us know how that
[Music]
goes oh thank
good
[Music]
oh hell yeah dude I love this stuff my
nose is messed up right now I need to
decongestion quick mine too that's oh my
gosh yeah have you ever tried this stuff
man you get uh you get uh little stuffy
nose every once in a while yeah this is
the best stuff to have clear clear with
an X get it you get it right cuz your
brother and the chair and this's awesome
man sometimes that was mine hey good
talking to you Chad no come come back
here come back
here we just we need to stop being
generous with our retainers the
contracts they're too long and we also
need to stop putting the clear on the
top shelf we do need to stop put it's
kind ofun not very fair fun but it's top
shelf stuff it is yeah actually can you
toss that yeah yeah
here that was not my fault I was
reaching for it maybe it's Tony or
whatever is I have no idea what you're
talking about but uh this is a sponsor
by the way they they found out because I
talked about it on the show and everyone
here is sick and myself included but I
tell you what most people are not even
showing up to the office just go and
check it out at clear.com it actually
like they're not they're allowed to say
this about the flu about Rhino virus
that it reduces viral load by an
incredible amount matter of fact it
deactivates the virus in your by like 90
something percent and then specifically
there was a placebo control covid study
yeah 62% Co reduction 62% when compared
to 62% and they weren't allowed to say
wer so now they have a huge lawsuit yeah
it's just uh you're washing your nose go
to clear.com and you can buy it at
Amazon or uh Sprouts we have here it's a
good one all right I feel better already
okay you know what here's the thing we
just talk and I reached for it theot and
I was like I was and I missed it and I
know Super Bowl's coming up I didn't
know until this weekend this is how
little I know about
sports that it's it's the rule that it's
legal to tackle a if they have the
braids in the that you're allowed to
grab the
braids okay so my my dad told me that I
was like what and he's like yeah but it
almost never happens somebody pull up a
picture of Derrick Henry for me in in
research do me Derrick Henry's hair it
looks like a turd on the back of his
neck this is easier he does a good job
though because he has that one big brain
list the point is it's a rule it's
allowed he's like yeah but very few
people do it I guess because it's poor
form yes I would if I were playing I
would do it all the time it would be
there needs to be one player there needs
to be one player in this league who
grabs every guy's stupid hair do that he
possibly can
it probably be some white cornfed guy
from Wisconsin in Green Bay he's like
it's the rule you want to be an idiot
and wear that hair and he would be like
the Grim Reaper where are you out of
your mind put your hair in a bun we're
playing Green Bay this weekend he's
going to grab it turd look at the I'm
sorry the a big turd it it does look
like a big turd unfortunately it's not
it's not his fault I guess it is because
it is his hair but you just grab that
and he's going down right no der he's a
train he's a freight train that guy he
is but you pull his head back and I mean
the the reason can do it is because you
can't make it harder to tackle Somebody
by having long hair I'm not saying that
you should do it incidentally I'm saying
that someone should be training in a
camp exclusively to
Target haircuts and just yank
them that's just be yanking them and
yank like look at the leverage I got I
don't care how and they like this guy is
crazy if you play him he's going you're
going to get Whiplash just one it just
takes one guy they're like this is the
swim move and then this is the hair move
yes exactly the problem is it's really
close uh to a horse collar tackle you
can like if you if you mess it up and
you don't grab the hair and you miss and
you grab the pads if you grab a guy by
the back of the pads and pull him down
it's a it's a huge penalty that's not
you're going to grab the wrong thing on
that guy he looks like one of those
in Jaba the Huts Lair true
that's true that's that is true crying
out loud it's like grabbing a serpent
what I miss one of those green ladies
you're right dude and by the way by the
way before you say it's racist you could
grab a white guy's mullet to the truth
is they just don't do it Matthew go it
happened him a lot he was a Packers
player he got yeah blonde no one does it
no one does it consistently why I mean
it's happened before but it's not a
consistent thing it's ridiculous it's a
frown upon thing it's all I would do it
would be ra on De is yes it
would all right you guys can comment
below if you think it's it's just not
cheap if it's the
rules I want men to Fe I want them to go
to the barber in a cold sweat like I
don't know I think I should just take it
off all right
that's been bothering you I don't know
where that came from So speaking of
weird haircuts uh MSNBC Joy Reed this
all started with
me don't look at it and let me I'm going
to set this up because you know it's the
it's the egene Carol story which you
know is is going to be how we we segue
into history isn't always how it's
remembered there are some really key uh
events in American history that you
think you think of as transparent one
way and that's not accurate and it's not
accurate because of conflicts of
interest that then become muddled over
time and they just hope that you don't
look it up so we have about five
examples uh throughout American history
and this is one of them with EEG Carrol
so we're going to clarify what it is
that's happened and I want you to think
of this story in 30 years time in 30
years time people will be saying oh yeah
that's right because Donald Trump's
sexually assaulted no no no no no no no
that's not even what happened right over
this week but that's how they will try
to write it so we'll make the references
available the truth matters this is how
the med sure their ratings suck sure a
lot of people aren't reading books or
these Publications from the left but
what happens is they chip chip chip chip
chip chip chip away and then history is
written not even by The Victors history
is written by the extremist people say
oh extreme left extreme right but the
extreme left dominate all forms of media
and now they're starting to dominate all
forms of New Media big Tech and so they
want history to be written one way
that's why I always say no no it's not
about just oh the moderate no no there
is no moderate leftist in the DNC and
there are no moderate leftists who head
up major Publications or news networks
or or by the way production companies
that's what worries me in 30 years time
will everyone be saying yeah the woman
who Donald Trump did not sexually
assault got insulted by the man who
didn't sexually assault her and then a
biased judge who had a conflict of
interest decided to uh hit him with a
multi-million dollar bill because that's
exactly what happened the left won't
even refute it they're just end dancing
end zone dancing anyway with the braid
so
msnbc's rough Monday started with Joy
Reed um uh I guess she's a frier you'll
see she's caught in a hot mic chastising
uh Joe Biden's foreign policy over the
weekend President Biden said he's ready
to take action if Congress is serious
about solving the Border issue she
joined some 41 that bill with the law
today I'd shut down the border right now
and fix it quickly and Congress needs to
get it done starting anothering
War
still trying to kill the
deal
whoops excuse me she she she did you see
that you see the hair she looks like fry
or dumb
so yeah nice pretty
good she just walking she was cancer
abuse like yeah so I was thinking like
what were you thinking that I would take
off a little bit I was thinking how
could you make me look worse could you
make me look like really dumb how do you
feel about blonde now she said at the
end of her show she said I was I was
chatting during a clip that was playing
and you know we try to keep the show
very PG-13 no one's concerned about the
profanity it's that you're a
liar fraud fraud fraud propagandist yeah
yeah there's plenty by the way that you
would find here during run through which
should never see the light of day but it
would never be
insincere it would be authentically
worse than what makes air yes sometimes
we sit here and everyone go like we will
run a bit and we'll go oh my God
no I'm sorry about that yes happens all
the time so but you wouldn't hear me say
Jo Joe Biden he just can't stop doing
good I just you know some you would
never hear
that that she doesn't believe what she's
selling she's like I said a bad word no
one gives no one cares you think we look
at you with those silly acrylic nails
and that hair do and think that you
speak like a choir boy no it's that
you're a
liar
okay Biden's like GH I should open that
border yes yes maybe some of them Willie
stylists so it got worse uh for MSNBC
when eege Carol this is a woman who
Donald Trump did not rape appeared on um
uh Mr Rachel matow show ranted about how
she would spend which looks really bad
when you try and say this isn't just
about money uhhuh then bragging about
how you want to spend the lawsuit money
and here she is um dressed in the uh
Thanksgiving uh table skirt you've
talked about using some of Trump's money
that you're about to get um to help
Shore up women's rights do you know what
that might be what that might look like
yes Rachel yes me I have such such great
ideas for all the good I'm going to do
with this money first thing Rachel you
and I are going to go sh shopping we're
going to get completely new wardrobes
new shoes motorcycle for c new fishing
rod for Robie Rachel what do you want
Penthouse it's yours Rachel Penthouse
and uh France you want France you want
to go fishing in France no she said
nothing all right all right okay pretend
to
laugh by the way don't you love how
she's picking out the least feminine
things ever she's like a new fishing rod
for this and a motorcycle for this
why a fishing rod
you three are regular Penthouse Letters
they're they got to go shopping but just
to talk to the manager yes exactly they
both have that haircut listen I want to
look this is you said you said festive
this is the Thanksgiving tablecloth I
want it to look like the Christmas table
don't forget the point like this yes
exactly her finger it's all know man did
you see her finger it's like broken or
something she grabbing Reese's Pieces
after seeing that I am convinced I do
believe that is Donald Trump's type yes
that is Donald Trump's type you know
since she goes we're going shopping so
that where they go to another dressing
room and pretend to get assaulted by
somebody yeah exactly well I mean you
know I do think Rachel mat will take her
up and you know she'll be going on a
spree at Men's Warehouse unfortunately
for een Carol you're going to like the
way you scissor for eene Carol the
settlement is actually $83 million in
Trump nfts so that she's not happy about
it that would explain the frowny oh jeez
that would explain space suit Trump that
was a good one that was a good one you
can make money off of it and by the way
we have this uh special coming up of
course on uh Thursday regarding the
Chinese communist government and the
grow Farms here in the United States if
you want to join mug Club none of this
happens without mug Club you can just
hit that button right now on Rumble and
uh we just introduced the new mugas
Option where it's just $9 a month yeah
we're not huge fans of it because of
course not only do you not get the
wonderful handes hand painted mug but uh
we plan out our year and the
investigations and the shows that we
bring on based on uh you know the annual
memberships but we also understand that
it's a rough economy thanks Obama I just
wanted to go earlier ni thanks Carter
wow went way back yeah uh so we need do
the $9 mugas option anything I'm missing
here nope no anything no
shopping crazy okay CRA
be crazy Donald Trump and egene Caroll
yeah that's the one he would sexually
assault okay so let me give you a recap
of what happened and uh I think you
probably know this but here's something
that's pretty important is a lot of the
people you're speaking with don't
most people you will be amazed as to how
many people and I don't mean that
they're dumb I'm not saying that the
American people are dumb that would be a
Bill Maher thing or some of the people
America's dumb no that's not the case
there are a lot of Americans who are
ignorant by Design because of an
artificial brain known as the algorithm
and that's what we've talked about
that's why we've done the Clean Slate
campaign if you want to know watch the
show you can watch this in context and
check the references a lot of people
will believe that Donald Trump just got
punished because he sexually assaulted a
woman exactly just like they believe it
was proven that he slept with Stormy
Daniels when the opposite was proven and
she owed his legal fees people still
believe that there are a lot of people
who still believe that January 6 was an
Insurrection where people actually broke
into the capital and killed five people
a lot of folks believe that so let me
clear this up for anyone who doesn't
know let me give you the easiest way to
explain it to the uninformed in your
life last week New York jury ordered
Donald Trump president Donald Trump to
pay $83 million to Ean Carroll for
defamation okay last fall judge Kaplan
ruled that Trump defamed Carol by saying
this is a woman who was claiming he
sexually assaulted her and Donald Trump
said I've never met this person in my
life she's trying to sell a new book
that should indicate her motivation it
should be sold in the fiction section
folks
that's that's $83 million seriously of
defamation the defamation is that Donald
Trump said he didn't bang
her I've defamed a lot of people yes yes
I can't believe that yes we' I've
defamed pretty much all of Earth I did
not bang Tim take that
[Music]
Tim $3 million for Donald Trump
defending himself saying I did not sleep
with this woman hey uh what what kind of
civil charges are went against Bill
Clinton for
actually actually sexually which
according to me too would be sexual
assault because the violation of power
you know also the weird stuff like using
cigars on an intern
what you don't know anyway so here's
something else too there's a conflict of
interest here at play and this is a
problem this is where you end up with
the Banana Republic it's not do you have
laws in the country it's are the laws
applied equally so Donald Trump's lawyer
Lena habba wrote a letter to the judge
in this CA uh case and she explained why
she will appeal and this is this is
pretty important as a result of a story
published in the New York Post defense
Council learned for the first time of
allegations that your honor while a
partner at the Paul Weiss for uh firm
had a mentor type relationship with
plaintiff's lead counsel meaning her
attorney Roberta Kaplan that seems like
a a a pretty big deal yes are the kinds
of things that you have to disclose the
very beginning of a trial or recuse
yourself from it and have some other
judge take it over yeah well that's the
law yeah you recuse yourself if there is
a conflict of interest well how's he
supposed to know he's a judge exactly
yeah you know it's just one of those
things law dude win some lose some I
mean maybe and speaking of conflict of
interest this is not the first time that
this has happened certainly as it
relates you know allegiance to a foreign
Nation uh by a presidential candidate
might qualify I told them that if they
would do this that South Carolina would
wrap their arms around them and take
care of them I now officially work for
you there is nothing that you can need
that we won't make sure that we deliver
yeah Josh Blue Star silicons is that
where Pelos Got Her Boobs hey now yes
um running for president running for
president I work for you okay then you
shouldn't work for us she also the
attorney um alleges in the letter that
Kaplan had a relationship with Carol's
other lawyer Sean Crowley here it is
this is uh from the New York Post this
issue is particularly concerning since
plaintiff's other lead counsel Shan
Crowley served as your honors law clerk
jeez and we were previously advised that
your honor co- officiated her wedding oh
wow God I mean the the connections are
loose now see if the judge were to say
now if the judge were to say I never Co
I co- officiated a wedding I never met
this person before in my life $83
million judgment right if well of course
in this case it would be a lie but the
point remains fully officiate the
wedding yeah EXA yeah was it's co-
there's like four other people
officiating that wedding there were a
lot of Judges it was a fashion thing we
were officiating weddings back then it
was a supreme court of a wedding so and
this is it kind of bothers me that that
they didn't figure this out prior to
trial as well right like Alena Haba I
mean maybe you know she's got other
things that she's working on and and I'm
not really criticizing her too much for
this but that is so obvious this is not
like something you had to go like seven
you know Six Degrees of Kevin Bacon deep
to find out it's yeah here's the wedding
photo oh I know that person right what
did you see her post uh her post-t trial
interview like right outside the
courthouse she pissed yeah she was
pissed but she also like told the media
that she couldn't say this beforehand
but they took all defenses away they
everything every defense they had they
they threw out and said they couldn't
use they threw out Witnesses they
couldn't use they gave surprise
Witnesses all kinds of things on top of
all that she couldn't even say anything
if she wanted to right and that's the
power of a judge that's what happens I
mean we'll get into gag order right yeah
there's a gag order and they'll often uh
enforce it in certain ways and not
enforce it in others and then you have
corrupt judges you have a illegal system
that can be worked yeah so there's
ignorance and then there there's also
inherent biases so for example a lot of
times judges will say I don't really
know how to deal with this this is the
first time in my courtroom and they will
ask the lawyers to send them a memo so
they can figure out how they rule on
motions that happens all the time it's
like hold on a second I need to send you
the law
judge but yes why are we here I need to
rule on it so there's that and then you
also have judge who let's say that they
do understand the law they also
understand how to work around it and of
course use the media as a strong arm
that happens a lot too for example
Trevor Bower he won his suit he lost
$100 million did he win Johnny Depp he
ended up winning he lost pirates of the
caraban whatever 19 I have no idea it's
14 hours long lot stuff a lot of lot
yeah did he win so there's the court and
there's the court of public opinion and
often these judges and a lot of these
corrupt lawyers they know how to use
both and if you have a judge who says
I'm going to enforce a gag order on one
side and not on this side it's not like
we haven't heard anything regarding this
case in EEG Carol everyone believes that
Donald Trump sexually assaulted her
everyone believes that Donald Trump is
guilty but his defense is not allowed to
present the conflict of interest no no
that's a violation of the gag order why
because I don't like it exactly because
I have a conflict of interest obviously
that would hurt my chances of giving my
friend the case yeah what am I going to
use my authority appropriately against
myself right are you stupid you don't
know how the world works and I think our
our research team can pull this up but I
think the Judge actually did Issue a
statement the earlier this week that
they had a problem with saying that
since he had been found guilty of sexual
assault or something like that and you
pointed out it was it was a Civil Trial
that's not a criminal it was a Civil
Trial and it was it was considered like
it could be a peck on the cheek right
right so the bar was really really low
for that and also she was the one who
kind of lobbied to make sure that the
what was it the they also changed the
statute of limitations so what happened
is they changed the statute of
limitations and it could have been a
peck on the cheek and then so they can
say actually we ruled that you did
sexually assault this woman because you
said she looked good in that dress and
that tablecloth she was wearing that day
and so for you to say you've never met
that woman in your life and to insult
her that's $83 million in psychological
damages that's the legal system well she
is damaged just not by him yeah yeah how
much damage do you think Monica Lewinsky
went through the thing about Monica
Lewinsky is she loved Bill Clinton that
was a thing it wasn't just a fair like
she was in love with him it's too bad
she could have got some money out of
that she could have gotten some money
out of that for crying out loud now you
have me too you have you have you have
uh was it MC Jagger David Bowie Tommy
Lee these people are coming forward 20
30 40 years later saying oh I went
backstage and then I ended up sing I
regret it hold on a second you went
backstage at a motly crew concert where
they were having an orgy look look rape
is a horrible thing but this can't just
become a 401k for groupies I let him
sniff Coke off my butt but then he
touched it yes
allegedly so let's go through some other
examples here and comment below uh lumpy
bud
I'm so stupid you're an cocaine
off the hipbones you're an go
ahead lumpy
Coke you know want lumpy Coke you really
don't man not from Egypt that's for sure
my cocaine's got fentanyl in it
all right the okay and and hit the like
button you know but what examples do you
think of when you think of the most
egregious sort of uh I points in history
that have become crystallized in a way
that is not true because of conflict of
interest or inherent biases either on uh
behalf of the legal system or the media
let me walk you through a couple here
are the ones that come to mind number uh
number one we'll go one through five um
Michael Brown the start of black lives
matter what everyone believes right
hands up don't shoot right now I know a
lot of you watching right now saying
this is remedial but you still have
people who repeat that that will be
written in history books it was hands up
don't shoot and this prick of an officer
Darren Wilson was out hunting black men
right that this policeman murdered
Michael Brown while he was on his knees
with his hands up telling the police not
to shoot him they portrayed him as this
gentle giant he had four members of
Congress who repeated hands up don't
shoot was all a lie hands up don't shoot
was a lie okay so the investigation
concluded that Mike Brown assaulted
officer Wilson just to be clear there's
no about that that Wilson feared that
Brown's blows could potentially render
him unconscious leaving him vulnerable
to additional harm and all of the
purported witnesses who claimed hands up
don't shoot acknowledged that they never
actually witnessed the shooting at all
but they had repeated what others had
told them in the immediate aftermath of
the shooting that's a direct quote for
example
reporters who were there hands up don't
shoot sounds a whole lot better than
beating a cop and reaching for his gun
after knocking over a liquor store Bas
and stealing cigarettes I don't know
what all he stole but I mean this wasn't
some just innocent guy walking around
happened to be in the wrong place at the
wrong time and they racist cop which is
what they want you to think and they
still paired it today hands up don't
shoot I guarantee you people still say
it today in positions of power that
should know better well because the
media did it non-stop you know you have
this right right here from CN why hands
up don't shoot resonates regardless of
evidence is
what shut up at that point like oh
that's that's how they walk it back yes
yeah there we go your kids and this is
the problem with putting your kids in
public education your kids 10 years from
now will be taught black lives matter
hands up don't shoot there was this boy
Michael Brown that's what they'll be
taught he was n years old he was 9 years
old just like they'll be taught een
Carroll was sexually assaulted by Donald
Trump and then a jury said you know what
we're your time's up buster and $83
million that's what we'll be taught
here's number two we've talked about it
on this show we'll make all these
references available I am amazed I hear
this all the time from that so so many
people out there because everything
becomes a gate yeah right every like
zipper gate Linsky gate zipper gate
Benghazi gate yeah one you that that was
in this office
but everything now is a gate security
gate yes that I ignored and jumped over
yeah I know but you shouldn't be doing
that by well and here's the thing
Watergate wasn't even the magnitude of a
gate when you know what Watergate
actually so many young people say what
really was Watergate okay let me explain
this one to you here's what everyone
believes that Richard Nixon ordered the
bugging of the Democratic headquarters
right that he ordered the bugging he was
spying on people and there was this big
uh there was this big conspiracy and
collusion here's what actually happened
Nixon didn't order the break-in okay
there's two guys it was a it was uh lyy
and um is it Howard hunt Howard hunt who
went in un Watergate is two dummies
unsuccessfully tried to bug these
headquarters at the Watergate hotel and
Nixon found out about it and said who's
the who's the who cleared that
and by the way if you're going to
actually uh just attempt to break the
law and create a conspiracy you
typically wouldn't have recording
devices in the Oval Office and In The
West Wing he recorded everything because
he wanted it for for the purposes of his
autobiography and for transparency
that's why when he heard about Watergate
he's like oh stop
talking can't say this here yeah what
it's not like your office is bugged Mr
President yeah we spying on I bugged my
own
office said don't tell on the phone that
fool me once and then what happened is
Richard Nixon attempted to cover up the
burglary for political purposes right he
was saying this is going to get back to
me people are going to say that I did
this a lot of that's that's what
Watergate is then there was Operation
deep throat that was some some member of
uh the media who was leaking some
information and they were trying to get
it and Nixon by the way resigned because
he didn't want people to lose all faith
in public office meanwhile we know that
Barack Obama was using the NSA to spy on
the Donald Trump campaign let's have
research bring that up as a as as a
reference so people just know that I'm
not lying but it's it's it's a fact it's
a it's it's an established fact
nothing nothing no consequences
whatsoever this is the problem that you
have is not whether we have laws is the
law applied equally and that also
translates to the media because they
work hand inand
they absolutely work hand in hand they
want someone out they will get someone
out you don't think that people in high
courts in this country you don't think
that people by the way who often
especially if you're a County judge you
have to raise money for your campaign
you don't think they've a vested
interest in damaging someone politically
MH this happens that's Watergate couple
guys tried to bug a hotel nothing came
from it happens all the time you can
even look at Hillary Clinton's emails
for cry out you can look at the
corruption that's happened recently
Nixon found out about it was super
pissed scared and then attempted to
cover it up because he didn't want to be
associated with it well I mean that's
his that's his crime right there the
crime was the cover up essentially and
but I I never knew that until you
started talking about that I never knew
that I just assumed because Nick you
know this was a long time ago and so you
really don't dig into a lot of these
things if it doesn't come up as
something else today but even in the
movie Frost Nixon they didn't put that
out right they didn't push that scenario
like hey this is actually what happened
it was just like Nixon did something
very bad by trying to bug these
headquarters that was what you thought
this entire situation was well thank God
we have president now who would never
try to cover something up never yes
exactly that's mostly it's the craps
that he takes in the places he's not
supposed to do that yes well you don't
cover him up you just change his diaper
yeah you just do it in front of the Pope
like I did another one in the hall and
just so you know Richard Nixon was
awesome it awesome like really really
good A lot of people don't know he got
us out of Vietnam of course he did it by
boming Cambodia that was kind of a screw
up but the point is a lot of people
don't realize that he did a lot of
things that people wanted and he this
you want to talk about a landslide map
Nixon not even close that a lot of
people don't know about Nix and they say
man what are the most corrupt presidents
ever Watergate that's what forced him to
resign yeah compared to Clinton compared
to I would even say certainly George
Bush Senior compared to Barack Obama
compared to Biden really Watergate that
some other guys tried to help you by
bugging a hotel yeah they just get away
with it now yeah Nixon did a lot of good
not perfect no one's perfect but I I
feel like history will look upon him a
lot more kindly okay let's go to example
number three here Alex Jones this case
this goes right to a legal
case uh here's probably what you believe
that Alex Jones denied that Sandy Hook
ever happened and he commanded his fans
to harass the families and that's why he
had to pay out the biggest civil
settlement that has ever taken place I
believe yeah here's what actually
happened Alex Jones uh is someone who
shoots from the hip not a not great with
impulse control uh we love you for he
had a call or call in and say that they
thought that Sandy Hook was uh that
there was something fishy there and Alex
Jones agreed he recanted his uh position
he he apologized to the families he
never called for the harassment of
families and Alex Jones people will say
he was found guilty of no Alex Jones was
found guilty by default by that judge
before it ever went to a jury
yeah but on a technicality there there
was no trial held now let me be really
clear about this and this wasn't proof
that Alex Jones called his fans to
damage uh the families of Sandy Hook it
was a default judgment and the reasoning
was uh what they call willful
non-compliance with Discovery so here's
the thing you had a judge in a court
that was asking Alex Jones for evidence
that he couldn't possibly produce they
said you have to hand over all these
financial documents Alex Jones said all
right here you go here's all the money
that I've made here's our Alexa ranking
here's and they said no no we want to
know the exact amount of money that you
made off of the Sandy Hook
conspiracy and Alex Jones which is very
very rare was that a loss for
wordss uh I don't know I guess we like
some ass like we spoke about it for
about 18 minutes over the course of
8,600 hours and uh we could do no no no
we want to know exactly how much revenue
was made from the Sandy Hook conspiracy
he said we don't have that it would be
like you asking how much of today's show
uh how much revenue was generated from
making fun of Joy Reed's silly monk wig
I wouldn't be able to tell you hopefully
a lot hopefully a lot hopefully that's a
few you know a few mug Club coins in the
fountain but I can't answer that a
couple of well wishes and so you have a
judge who has all these finances you
have a judge who literally has Alex
Jones's private texts and says yeah yeah
but I'm asking for something specific
and since you didn't since you didn't
hand that exact number over guilty yeah
and then it was just a matter of
determining the number of Dames which is
what you saw Alex testifying to in the
trial and people were like oh well Alex
Jones got on the stand and he just he
couldn't answer the questions no no no
no the verdict was already in at that
point exact this was just seeing how bad
how how much of an overreach there was
going to be on the judgment and in case
you didn't already know that it was
corrupt uh you know I would say that a
judgment that is more than his company
has ever made in the history of ever
ever ever and could ever make over the
next decade billion might be a little
extreme like yes they're never going to
see any of that money Ean Carol is never
going to see any of that money she
should never they should never I'm sorry
bad things happen in life and Alex Jones
didn't cause people by saying go to
which was kind of the line that we're
supposed to draw there didn't cause
those people to go after you and this
happens all the time and you still have
people who say well Alex Jones shouldn't
have sent his fans after the Sandy Hook
people he was found guilty because
that's what he did that's not what
happened all references are available
Link in the description the whole I mean
you talk about Banana Republic this one
was a bigger miscarriage of Justice than
than Mr Christie versus Cookie Monster
and that one jeez that one was
rough the pillows in the backround I
think that jury definitely has uh some
biases yeah they have it out for them
that's what I'm saying they need to be
sequestered he need send the milk after
them he needs a new
jury you can't handle the
milk sounded like the Q and on Shaman a
little bit there little bit put that
cook it
down this is Sesame court so here's uh
number four and this is one that uh
again we're just going through this
because these there things that people
really believe that are just patently
false either because of the legal system
or the media and they're often one and
the same Bill Clinton the sex scandal
here's what a lot of people believe
right that the the news of Bill
Clinton's affair with Monica winsky that
it was shocking to everyone okay so I'm
not saying that this eventually wasn't
covered what I'm saying is the story was
bombshell here's what actually happened
this is what built the Drudge Report
Matt drudge yeah he reported on the
story after it had been punted killed by
Newsweek and other republications this
was a wellknown Open Secret in political
circles not to mention all of the other
women who he bangs some of whom
allegedly unwillingly so a lot of people
think oh my gosh this was this bombshell
and no no what happened is for years
they were covering up for Bill Clin and
even as it related to Monica Lewinsky it
was welln there were publicans out there
that knew it and they decided not to
cover it that's what built Matt drudge
the first sort of New Media star The
Drudge Report doesn't exist if the media
did not cover up for Bill Clinton think
of that conflict of interest you know
about Monica Lewinsky you know about her
being as little humidor you know about
the dress a lot of people don't know
that the media knew about it and said
we're not going to cover it but we're
talking about Donald Trump maybe at some
point telling egene Carol that she had
nice tits which he says he
didn't well we can see clearly she
doesn't yes that's true that's
true let's call a Pity compliment that's
true that
I did you did everyone here know that
did everyone here know that that that it
got punted by Newsweek and the it
doesn't surprise me that it was an Open
Secret I mean everybody knew that you
know the stuff with JFK and it's kind of
this Open Secret that didn't really get
put out there there was kind of this
Camelot kind of mentality right and I I
get it I understand that they've kind of
carried the water for a long time but
when you go back and look at Bill
Clinton now thankfully there's enough
reporting on him where people's like oh
yeah of course he slept he probably
slept with everybody yeah right we Now
understand that but at the time the only
one yeah it was it was shocking when he
goes on TV and says that he did not have
sexual relations with that woman I
believe is the wording that he chose
Hillary Clinton was so upset when she
saw that press conference she dropped
her turkey
baster she let me murder to guy
allegedly and and the point here is look
just because people will try and tell
you oh a conspiracy take the let's take
the blinders off here there's no doubt
about anything that I'm telling you
today I tried to pick the ones that are
now unilaterally agreed upon so that you
can see how people were actually gas lit
back then and now we say Okay that was
true this is exactly what's happening
right now with Donald Trump and Ean
Carol you kind of know that that's what
happened with January 6th yeah um let's
go to another one here uh Clarence
Thomas this is one where if you're
younger you probably have a certain idea
of Clarence Thomas by the way this is
what turned Andrew Breitbart he was a
liberal in Brentwood and he tuned in to
watch Clarence Thomas get his come up
and and he said oh my God I can't
believe that they're trying to destroy
this man so here's what you probably
here's what's taught that Clarence
Thomas sexually harassed uh uh Anita uh
Anita I Anita Hill his uh a one of his
AIDS he didn't have AIDS just to be
clear just different AIDS here's what
happened no okay that's not what
happened and uh that was even from the
FBI at that point and I don't trust them
any further than I can throw them which
is pretty far they tend to be small guys
that's an overlay there from CNN uh
Thomas characterized the allegations as
and this became a famous quote uh
high-tech lynching okay and what he W
what actually happened and this is true
is in his office on a Diet Coke can
there was a hair on it and he said hey
who put their short and curly who put
their you know pubic hair on my Coke can
that was it that was it which makes me
like him makes me like him makes me want
to party with Clarence Thomas makes want
to put some pubes on his Coke exactly
you're like Josh he did it again you
jackass I'm going to call you Mr puber
Coke
can that's that's good name for you it's
like I don't think that's a great
nickname I'll work on it
but so that gets turned into sexual
harassment and then what do they try and
do just like you saw with Brett
Kavanaugh they tried to extrapolate and
say there was a big story about him
going to this porn store I believe I
believe when he was in DC and then they
found out hold on a second this porn
store actually didn't exist at the time
that he lived in this location and there
would have been a porn store much closer
to where he actually did live and they
never saw him also he would probably
send an assistant so all of these
stories came out the true portion is he
made a joke about what seemed to be a
pubic hair on a can of Diet
Coke but history has tried to paint him
as a sex offender yeah Bill Clinton
history has tried to paint as some kind
of a bombshell oh my gosh reporting no
they and this is what they always think
about this we see Watergate in deep
throat we look at it we go my gosh
journalism the golden air can you tell
me something can let me ask you this
when did the Golden Age of Journalism
stop cuz I don't buy it I'm sorry I even
conservatives saying it back in the day
when media when when was there a golden
era of of Journalism and when did it
stop obviously not with
Watergate obviously not with JFK because
they weren't reporting back then that he
was banging everyone right uh obviously
not with Bill
Clinton obviously not with even during
the Reagan Era the guy could do no right
so when people say thatour uh
journalists used to be objective when
when did when did journalism exist as an
objective craft and when did it change
when people say that I say okay great
when did it
change let's go back to the people who
you know you're talking about people who
won polers you're talking about people
who want every Emy Dan Rather
liar Walter kronite liar Larry
King empty suit looks like an owl it
doesn't matter how far back you go
you're like he's honest but uh look at
him he's an idiot yeah he's an idiot so
Jerry Seinfeld what's the name what's
the name of your show let's get some
suspenders on Stephen what it's a sitcom
correct okay
Larry it's always been Folly it's just
that now you get to see it you think
that this happened if Donald Trump let's
say he was he was President uh he
happened to be president in the 1970s
you think everyone out there would have
gotten the true story of egene
Carroll what about Hunter Biden if if if
this was the era of Walter kronite and
Dan Rather insert whoever here guess
what that never would have even been a
scandal because no one would have known
about it because no one else could have
told you that it was covered up exactly
also e carot was sleeping with JFK yes
well everyone was well he said he was
she wasn't his type either but he said
she was he said she's not my type but
you know what uh at the end of the day
right now I don't have anyone on call
yeah he's he's like I can either get in
this limo that doesn't have a top and go
down a street where people want to kill
me or hang out with egene Carol yes
exactly he got in the car yeah
yes
he was in a convertible because he was
tired of hearing Jackie O like aop
never stop talking put me in the
convertible by God I want to hear all
the people like sir you could get shot I
should be so lucky need my wife
like I need a hole in the head
yes wish granted oh jeez no and people
so Hillary killed his uncle yes yeah no
nobody nobody would have known different
how many I guarantee you right now it's
it's the same as it has always been
right we just didn't know about it then
they controlled information better back
then and so we didn't have the ability I
guarantee if we go back into these
stories if we had the ability to jump in
a DeLorean and go investigate these
things we would see like holy crap
they're covering this up but nobody
knows right they can't know there is no
social media there is no way to get
information out around The Gatekeepers
that existed back then and they knew
better they knew all these people
reporting on this all of these people
doing these things talking about
Clarence Thomas talking about Judge
Kavanaugh all they knew better at the
time but they did it anyway right the
culture back then too I will say that
like if if this exact case that EEG and
Carol had happened in the 70s most men
would have been like
yeah okay yeah whatever what wait she
says he did he says that he didn't what
was he doing at Blooming deals yeah
exactly isn't that where a woman goes
right yeah they would have not they
would have not voted him because they
thought he was a big exactly
you're not guilty but you're also not
president yes you're also not my kind of
President would have done it would have
a t-shirt blooming deals not my
president No Effects would write a song
and here's a bonus one by the way Peter
Navaro this is another one because this
is more recent what a lot of people
believe is that you know this uh this
Trump Administration their aid Peter
Navaro you've heard the name that he was
he was punished and rightful because he
broke the law he broke the law he
ignored a congressional subpoena he
broke the law that has consequences well
again are the laws applied equally
here's the truth Navaro was literally
the first person incarcerated for
defying a congressional subpoena in over
50 years now I know you're saying yeah
yeah but on the other people no no
remember o the Obama's Attorney General
Eric Holder yeah he defied a
congressional subpoena with zero
consequence he also refused to produce
any documents and the Fast and Furious
Scandal this is where guns were
basically being uh just they were being
fast laned across the border and he was
head of the doj when the doj refused to
prosecute so you hear about Peter Navar
you go well he ignored a subpoena that's
what it's like jury duty you toss it in
the you toss it in the waste paper B and
you hope it solves itself he's not the
only guy who denied he refused to show
up for a congressional subpoena it
happens all the time you shouldn't do it
no one's been put in jail for it in over
50 years including the attorney general
who lied to Congress and was convicted
by Congress of lying to Congress and
nothing happened to it and by the way do
you know what the the The subpoena was
for oh the January 6 committee that was
a complete sham that was an absolute
joke of a show trial for the American
public it was so important that he be
there for that that they're not going to
put him in jail for the first time in 50
years somebody's being punished for it
for that right any excuse to put someone
behind bars yeah that's the that's the
left agenda that's their plan now of
course we can't forget you know the
obvious one the inherent bias of the
judge in the OJ Simpson case well
that's come on he's absolutely a Bills
fan thean of the juice yes so we've got
is the lose e and Carol is not all that
different from the Alex Jones trial
lence Thomas Watergate what happened
with Bill Clinton what's happened with
Peter Navaro hands up don't shoot this
happens all the time and it is collusion
between a complicit media and a judicial
system that really is not all that uh
interested in many cases in
administering Justice let's just be
really clear about that and if there are
other examples that you can think of
that I've missed please let me know I
wanted to start with some stories about
which there can be no doubt about which
there can be no debate so you go oh yeah
hold on a second we weren't crazy we
weren't crazy when that happened and
this is not going to stop because they
don't want this guy in office and they
know that he would beat Biden like a
rented mule if the election were held
today that's what's
happening and by the way Nixon same
thing one of the most popular presidents
in the country until Watergate to be
clear this is what they do they go after
it's it's a lynching yeah and they hope
that you're still dumb enough to buy it
so I know we went Ma you know every now
and then we just say let's kind of pull
out here and let's see if folks remember
these things you let us know if that's
something that you like and by the way
uh we do have the uh $9 mugas option if
you want to continue with mug are you
looking at something is there well no I
a quick update this was a good catch uh
Hunter Biden actually defied a subpoena
I wanted this I didn't want to sound
stupid but I thought that that was true
okay I'm just I'm just curious when he's
going to get sentenced to uh to time in
prison yeah for just for that I mean
there's a bunch of other things he needs
time in prison for but nonetheless
when's he going to get put in prison for
Hey when's Ray EPS going to be put in
prison there you go remember that
January 6 other people who people who
just happened to be the Q and on yeah
the Qin on Shaman was invited into the
White House it's on camera there's no
doubt Congress White House yeah oh sorry
the White House sorry yeah he wasg no
you're absolutely right you can admonish
me for that sorry the White House with
all of the protesters right uh trying to
break down the fence and get into the
White House and burning down a
church yeah that's what happened uh not
too long before that good point
sometimes I jumble them in my brain
silly me hit him most dangerous day in
American history most dangerous day 911
harder so this man Q non Shaman gets
invited in all right that guy spent time
in jail how long was it how many it was
over a year I think he got sentenced to
four years he spent a couple years he
spent a couple of years Ray EPS who's
there saying we need to March into the
Capitol Building let's go in there come
on guys we need to all on
camera basically time uh time served
house arrest that guy's not going to do
anytime it sounds like what they accused
elex Jones of doing sounds tell your
fans to go do something allegedly yes
the only issue is rups didn't have any
fans so true aside from the the feds
well he didn't do it on the radio he or
the internet he did it in live in person
hey we also remember Governor Whitmer
Michigan you probably heard that there
was a plot to kidnapp her oh yes you
didn't hear that the majority of people
involved in that plot were federal
agents and she's going to run for
national office and that'll be a huge
thing it's someone who survived a
kidnapping attempt and by the way his
husband said
keeper
so don't have her yet that was an
overreaction sorry yeah I know the guy
who her husband called who asked him to
lower the boat can you lower like we
can't lower anyone's boates because of
Co and this Governor he's like
well you know who's married to that
the guy's like thanks click yeah I
know who to blame yeah I know exactly
who to blame there's so much that people
believe to be true and it just requires
enough it just requires enough people
who aren't engaged that then these
things pick up steam and they become uh
written in you know etched in stone
that's the issue and they want to do
that with een Carroll they want to do it
with January 6th they want to do it with
Mara Lago being being worth $18 million
hey what why is it worth 18 million
because the judge ruled it so ah people
believe that too anybody they're going
to try to get him for $360 million in
fees to his businesses and barn from
doing business in New York by the way
the bank doesn't care because they got
paid everybody won there Trump doesn't
care because he paid all of his bills
off for that and by the way it's the
bank's responsibility to confirm what
the assets are worth when they're
issuing a loan anyway way so it
shouldn't even be a case but the judge
said it's $18
million okay maybe the flag pole yes
exactly empty lots a fraction of the
size are worth are going for $18 million
maybe it was $17 million Maraga it's
crazy they awarded een Carol four times
that amount yes I know they buos four
well I mean realistically she could buy
two yeah yes yeah maybe because that
assessments BS but that's CRA that's a
that's a weird way to at it you know
we're going to continue this segment too
on mug Club but this is another example
of just sort of just in case you had any
faith left and I will say this like this
is where Nixon was wrong the reason the
reason he resigned was because and he
said I want people to think that public
service is still a noble uh profession
it's not just to be clear it's not let's
get rid of the term public servants they
should immediately be met with
skepticism there should be no hero
worship of anyone it should be as though
they're on bad behavior and maybe
they're on Furlow that's how we treat
politicians but certainly the media I
actually do want to see distrust in
institutions that have lost your trust
here's another this comes from Yahoo
okay they dropped an article on Saturday
the 15 unhappiest states in the United
States come
on come on W Virginia how you going to
be unhappy when you marry your sister
and in there you have Texas and
Tennessee I'm happier than a fish in
water 13 out of 15 of the states are
clearly Republican every state in the
top five Kentucky Arkansas Tennessee
Louisiana Virginia now here's the issue
it conflicts West Virginia let's I say
sorry West Virginia yes I'm sorry other
Virginia is different their other
Virginia is different by the way
Virginia as a state it's ridiculous it's
it's completely you have a few people
who are close to DC who are have nothing
in common with the other people in the
state and they they vote the entire
state in an election um this article
conflicts with all the real world data
that we have like this is a very
important point in 2023 okay uh people
who moved across States like you can
look at the four biggest states Florida
Texas New York California okay shrinkage
and shrinkage in California and New York
record growth it was cold in Florida and
Texas that's that's about as good of an
example as you get right in other words
people say oh you can't really compare
rhod Island oh you know what these are
fair comparisons Texas Florida New York
California all right states are
shrinking states are being crippled
economically and these ones are doing
well two red two blue the biggest states
that you have a very very stark
contrast so do you think this list was
created with objective standards did
they look at unemployment rate did they
look at Cost of Living did they look at
uh population growth no no of course it
didn't it was entirely subjective
standards from the media just like this
is something I've talked about with you
in the past when they would try and say
you know America actually United States
has one of the worst Healthcare systems
that we're we're actually ranked I think
number 37th yeah we were ranked below
Colombia and Cuba think about that list
for a
second it's not real I can't make I
can't start my own cartel this country
sucks yes exactly because it was
subjective rankings of asking people hey
do you like your Healthcare who with a
pistol to their head in Cuba is going to
say no to be fair the to be fair the
gets processed a lot before it gets from
colia here so maybe that's what they're
upset about I believe if someone pulls
up that list I believe we were like
right neck and neck with Colombia we
were below countries that don't even
have MRI it was absurd yeah yeah and and
then that gets pared for all the time we
have this horrible Health we have a we
have a healthcare system that could that
could improve absolutely but that's not
true it's the same thing with this list
of states they're trying to force
journalists are not trying to report on
opinions they're trying to create create
opinions and my question for you is we
just went through Watergate we went
through the Clinton scan we went through
Clarence Thomas we went through Peter
Navaro we went through hands up don't
shoot you can go all the way back if
there was a golden age of
Journalism when and when did it change
and when you understand that it's one of
the most powerful tools that judges and
lawyers have to use that's when you get
the cold chill down your spine and you
realize that you are no longer in a free
country that's what that's about so
we're going to talk about this more this
silly article yeah it's it just gets
more dumb and I need to I when it's
funny when I'm mad when I'm mad I like
the sensation to go to the B to pee iser
it's elevated angry pee I've heard it
before and he take ceramic off that
toilet I yes I do a power washer maybe
if it was a Colombian toilet he'd be a
lot better of a pee but well careful now
don't turn on 1% of our viewers right
now you degenerate you hey you're better
than that get your head out of the
gutter if you're watching on Rumble
click this button you can continue
watching on uh mug Club if you're not I
don't know what you're doing you're on
YouTube we appreciate you but right now
we say you to piss
[Applause]
off
yeah